blow take it alert gang get your tickets
to The Gramercy theater and come out and
see the boys February 3rd yeah gang it's
our third show we added the Army garbage
came out strong sold out the first two
we added a third let's sell this last
one out we love you as let's do it
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash now
here are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H
Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is are you garbage oh yeah it's a little
show we sit down with your favorite
comedians and we find it at the group to
be classy Earth are just a big old piece
of trash I'm your host Dave trolley
coming at you on a beautiful day we're
down here at antuti's basement she's
upstairs shredding documents okay tax
season end of the year baby my co-host
is coming at you from right next to me
he is the CEO of Ru garbage he is an
international businessman he's the
prince of Park Avenue but always no
matter what time of the year King of the
boardwalk baby give it up for KJ Kevin
James Ryan what up gang thanks for
tuning in as always please make sure
your rate if you subscribe on iTunes
full video available on YouTube as you
know those numbers are cooking over
there then obviously the greatest
website of all time
www.patreon.com garbage check it out
we're about to announce our tour in like
a week or two check it out get ready for
them live shows baby yeah we're coming
gang and having a nice quick shout out
to our producer extraordinaire the magic
man makes us all look good works the
ones work works the twos crosses the t's
dots the eyes give it up for T-Bone
mcgruffins it's Toby McMullen everybody
how about that hey what up dude yeah we
got a Hall of Fame guest in here
where you could pick your uncle this
guy's going first round every time shout
out to Uncle Paulie man clean as a
whistle this kid
you can cut steak on that beard line
look at him
the long hair ain't lying we couldn't be
more excited to have our incredibly
special guests back with us again today
he's family at this point you know him
you love him has an amazing special out
on Netflix right now kicked off a brand
new tour right now you gotta go see him
ladies and gentlemen give it up for the
cleanest guy in town Paul verzy
everybody let's go come on my favorite
podcast
my favorite podcast in the world this is
number three for me there you go It's
gotta be no I think it's more than that
maybe there's this three I I call Paul a
liar I'm sorry Mr Mercy I apologize I
think this might be four I'm just gonna
get both of us
he's here as many times as he says I
mean this guy's correcting compliments
I'm like
you know what the [ __ ] go [ __ ] yourself
how about that
drove down from the house drove down
from the house cars clean as a whistle
dude just bought one wow
I just bought one wait a minute a week
ago
Toyota Corolla right
I picture you as a Hyundai man
you know I was gonna go electric and
then I decided with everything going on
with the electrics and how long they
were taking and they're not ready it's
not ready it's not there yet it's not
there yet
um so I decided to stay with Lexus there
you go but here's the company man yeah
the thing though you guys you'll love
this you'll [ __ ] love this I kept
telling them I go listen I need dark
outside and I need white inside who are
you straightening out this poor bastard
at the dealership yeah he's like Paul
and Paul he's like I can't I go I want
white leather inside and dark out he
goes he goes there's two in the country
that has the white inside and he goes
one and I go Jeter owns one of them
so he kept calling he's like Paul I
can't do it I can't do it and I go all
right well then so I started to look
where I could get it and I found this
car beautiful like dark dark gray which
sometimes looks black and it's so light
inside dude it's like when you open the
door it's like heaven dude it just pops
right it just pops the details dude the
attention to detail Mr verzie is thrown
around the wood is black
yeah nobody has black one
nobody gets Onyx wood
a black [ __ ] wood that's too funny
okay all my friends joked like they were
like versus yeah Italians like white
because they think it reminds me of
heaven and maybe but dude you open the
door and the door is just and it's so I
got this i got this Lexus it's white
inside it's dark gray outside all the
trim on it's it's gorgeous Carl you know
white kids kids and wife really not
allowed in it real like I mean yeah
definitely no food in there I mean it
got to the point where I was I had to
look at my son in the eyes and go
Candy's not happening yeah like because
they you know they get the rappers they
get the candy can't even have a cough
drop in there
I don't care I had your how bad your
bronchitis we went to the mall he goes
dad can I get candy and I go yeah but he
can't open yeah keep it in the trunk
open it up when we get to the house yeah
put that [ __ ] my golf bag in the trunk I
like it's weed or something is the golf
bag always in the trunk well not with
the new now the new car I don't want
anything in it so there's literally
nothing in my car the first time I got
in the Lexus yeah was way back in the
day we were doing something leave it
somewhere where bananas are somewhere
together yeah and uh he goes oh we're
gonna let's go smoke a stick I get in
the car he's like he's open he's like
nice car how to get in we can sit down
nice car I go yeah it's my score he
wants the confirmation once you're in a
nice car right I like the car right yeah
is there is there a rag in there do you
keep a rag like something just to do it
or whatever no but I I got a 2 900 I
bought a 2900 like seven details by the
dealership oh nice so I could take it to
Lexus like seven times and it comes out
like showroom that's awesome you know it
costs a few grams sure they actually
recycle the air in the car like they
there's a whole thing really yeah most
sisters yeah they do some like they like
it's like brand new like they seal it up
new air so I was like yeah there is
nothing better than getting the car a
freshwater you want to laugh Italians
like anything yeah I'll take that new
air you got
I need your lifetime vacuums
it's the same air they put in Celine
Dion's car right there I'd say get it
from Vegas believe that [ __ ] smell it
smell it you can smell the chips did a
liberal on this car
I want something that hasn't even been
through San Francisco all right
do you have the uh do you have the
remote start uh yeah do you in the
winter time do you preheat before you
well I got I got it on the app too so
it's an app now so what I do is Alexis
has an app on my iPhone so I could lock
the doors I could start I could get the
temperature how I wanted the whole thing
I think I needed to get a radio station
I want
like I just walk into exactly how I need
it yeah is it an Uber black do you park
in the garage at the house or you keep
it on you keep it in the driveway no I
keep it in the driveway I keep it in the
driveway we have a two car but we're
trying to decide if we're going to turn
that into something we don't really use
the you know okay and my wife's with
Lexus too so we kind of he says it like
they signed the contract
what's an agency yeah but I tell the guy
I'm like look we're staying with you you
guys my dad did the same thing with Jeep
for a long time they loved that [ __ ] the
loyal customer base oh yeah that was
filled with bad air I'm sure
dude I had a buddy I had a buddy name
named Nick right his dad was this over
the top Italian kid big time Big Guy
they were with Chevy for 30 years
they were with Chevy for 30 years right
so he goes there right it's Upstate New
York and he just the guy comes out with
it was like a new sales guy and they
give it they don't like that they give
them enough they give them the number
and he said his dad just sits back and
he goes
I've been coming here for 25 [ __ ]
years he goes go get the [ __ ] up you
go back in that office and you come out
with numbers that make sense or I'm
[ __ ] hey give me the 25 year numbers
screaming screaming the whole thing and
the guy came out and goes oh no it's him
listen like we don't even want the
headache yeah
30 years give him what he wants and get
the [ __ ] out of here that's what I'm
going to that's what I'm trying to get
respect trying to get that with Lexus
when they see Paulie walk in the door
it's like listen he's gonna stay with us
right about the wood tone and everything
but we got to get him yeah yeah three
white cows are getting shot
right there have it ready for you in a
couple of weeks Paul
when was he killed
today what is this
I want something in the face so his
mother can't give him an open Candy
oh man
um we've been talking lately yeah uh on
the old patreon there about what kind of
Readiness that we have in case something
popped off we were thinking like
apocalypse type [ __ ] okay how ready do
you think you would be if it popped off
Oh you mean like if this was unexpected
Papa expected you had like a rumbling of
a day or two like how this might happen
but you're going I don't know how ready
would I be as far as like supplies
supplies
plan where are you going what are you
doing you got a crew you can link up
with all right look I got a thousand
bullets okay
no I do I have a thousand bullets I
bought a bike and throw them [ __ ]
quick I bought a box of a thousand okay
okay got a thousand rounds I got a
thousand rounds no gun and it's a 10
shoe it's a 10 shot semi okay okay so I
got I got a I got a couple days to fight
we got some knives my wife has a hatchet
that you know I got something from a
sponsor you know putting her on Hatchet
Duty yeah
where's the chivalry well listen I shoot
the kid in the head she [ __ ] cleaned
it up and she chops them up
they got the wife on screwdriver detail
I I don't you know what water wise like
like water like we don't have the
gallons lined up we're not one of those
preppers you know which we found out a
lot of like we asked the list of dude
they came in people like I got 50 000
rounds I got water for five months
stocked up on diesels yeah people are
like I got like 80 gallons of cooking oh
you guys got people that there's some
people out in Wyoming that are [ __ ]
ready are you on a well up there yes you
guys you guys well that's probably
that'll stay good right oh well yeah
plus you can get to it I think right
yeah no the well the I think like the
regular but I'm talking about having
jugs right yeah you have jugs ready I
don't think we would you'd be all right
yeah you're making me think dude we
started talking I'm about to buy land in
the Poconos to get the [ __ ] out of town
and [ __ ] happens I got a thousand
bottles of Gatorade like what happened
on are you garbage
why are you wearing a gas mask what the
[ __ ] you doing Paul shut up and fill up
the tub
where are my bullets why is my hatchet
on my pillow
I'd buy a freezer
[Laughter]
do you have a separate freezer do you
have like a meat freezer now we have we
don't have the separate meat freezer we
have another fridge right we have a
secondary fridge downstairs which stocks
like a lot of the drinks the extra stuff
yeah sure but we don't have that meat
locker gotcha so yeah the more I think
about this you're doing the deer up
there though yeah we could shoot a deer
we could lure them out with apples in
the backyard and clip one Wildlife we
could probably eat for a while that's
yeah sure you know would you link up
with Yanni P do you think yeah because
we went together for the gun so he's got
a thousand rounds too there you go so we
so together we could you know I could
just picture them through cleaning their
guns oh man oh no I picture you guys
buying those guns like if you're getting
500 I'm getting a thousand yeah dude one
up on each other dude one of the
funniest things is when we bought the
guns [ __ ] our wives were really pissed
off but he's like dude she said I gotta
get a watermelon too he showed up to his
house he had a watermelon under one arm
and got a rightful and a thousand rounds
in the other
and she's like what the [ __ ] she's like
well you got a gun he's like I got them
it's a summer a refreshing treat for you
but yeah I think see the nice thing is
see I'm elevated okay
I'm on a hill on a mountain a lot of
people are only on one I'm on both so
I'm on the mountain that's with a hill
on the [ __ ] thing I'm 800 feet high
and or the hill we're all kind of know
each other we're all family we'd have to
band together so we would band together
we get our guns we get our hands we
could blow a couple of those trees too
so nobody can get up the roadways yeah
there you go make a blockade yeah yeah
he's thinking dude I just don't I just
saw the motor start turning numbers
yeah we got a there's a couple of
neighbors right neighbor across streets
a cop there you go so he's got he's lost
and he's like he's got he's like dude if
anybody comes near to come here he's
like everybody he's like I'm outside
with the gun and like he's I was like
all right so it's not crazy
yeah this guy's gonna [ __ ] snipe out
my dog thinking it's a wild coyote I'm
like dude relax
so that's the plan that's pretty good
that's not bad you're way better
prepared than we are I mean is there
anywhere you would bolt to where would
you go or that would be you would just
that would be the album study at the
crib yeah I'm so far off yeah
there's a lot of woods we have actually
more Woods we can go to so I think we
would just like hunker down where we are
strategically and figure it out yeah
yeah I think so you know I mean I like
it now what if we came staggering up the
hill Oh I mean you guys are you guys are
more than what do you mean stagger you
guys drinking are you guys are you guys
bleeding zombies like they already got
you like I love you guys but you come up
bleeding I'll be like listen Hank you
got 10 minutes left
I'll make a phone call for you but I
can't I mean my white I got white
leather
definitely get in a car I'll let you in
a property you ain't getting a car oh
send it to take him to the emergency
room I mean use your car you got black
leather
this guy's not gonna bleed out
but if I saw you guys like tired alive
and everything I would obviously be like
yeah of course but even if I you know
even if I saw you guys bleeding you just
wouldn't go in a car yeah
fine Leathers fine leather at the end of
the day find you a nice find you a nice
spot in the shed Hank
but you lick those wounds for a little
while see if you turn into a zombie
that's good stuff man I like him that's
good let's do some cues here yeah gang
uh as you know when you sign up for the
patreon we will answer your garbage
question on the air it's just the best
way to do it we got a lot of submissions
but patreon gets the first crack at it
um this one we've never talked about uh
this is from Gary he goes I know we've
agreed first of all do you pee in the
shower yeah yeah yeah let it fly if you
have to because I know we've all agreed
peeing in the shower while showering is
fair game was it trash to pee at the
shower at the gym
I I I would never in a million years
shower to Jim really I'm kind of the
same way I mean I could be soaking wet
sweat I'm just gonna dry off as much as
I can and get home yeah I can't I'm not
a big communal
showering locker room guy I've done it
but it doesn't it's not a great shower
unless you have all this if you have
your soap if you have your towels all
that stuff you're using one of those
little towels that they have and you're
using those dispensers what are you
gonna be like excuse me bud you [ __ ]
hit the gel thing yeah get the hand
sanitizer going or whatever let me get
two squirts pal like no dude and that
stuff's like agent orange man that [ __ ]
drives you the [ __ ] out whatever they
put in there I think it's Palm Olive
dries you out a shower to me is kind of
a kind of almost like your Sanctuary
it's a ritual it's an intimate thing you
have your thing you kind of your
thoughts the hot water like I can't be
with some you know guy that just worked
out and we I'm not into that you don't
want to wear flip-flops in the shower no
yeah no no I'm not wearing flip-flops it
makes sense yeah yeah it makes sense he
has a shower at the gym to stuff I mean
obviously you know you do what you have
to do I mean to piss in the shower in
the gym you're just a [ __ ] animal
like with other people I might have done
it no I've definitely done it yeah I
might that's Lawless as far as I'm
concerned I know wait but there's other
people with this with you no I don't
think they have them it's not like
Rikers it's not like a prison no yeah
the one I've been in was that really
yeah yeah yeah I was a kid oh all right
now think about it what the [ __ ] was my
dad that explains a lot I mean the bath
house
Jesus Christ Pops that was fully closed
it didn't even work out either now they
think about it you're like yeah Sandusky
that's normal
yeah I don't think now they have them
like groups like that I think they're
like little individual stalls I did it
recently
that's different yeah if it's like your
own little thing and you have to piss
that's a different ballgame sure but if
they're yeah but because I also think
somebody else is if I've thought about
it someone else has done it someone else
before you after you was gonna pee in
there so it's like and P's not dirty
theoretically it ain't clean I mean I
thought something you don't want to be
standing in someone else's urine but
then why do you why do you pee on like
uh mosquito bites or whatever I don't
think you do that well I don't know what
you're doing at your place who does
jellyfish bites I thought it had some
kind of how often does that happening
it's a common occurrence
I thought it had antiseptic qualities to
it it does it's I think it's like it has
something in it but that's the only
thing it's not like you stub your toe
you pee on it you know what I mean it's
like yeah that's it you said that what
about if you have to suck the venom out
I've got a snake like that's not no that
doesn't happen is that a real thing by
the way because I was in a movie
you get the poison in you no but you
spit it out no it's still in your mouth
it's not supposed to get in your
bloodstream as quick the old yeah it's
got to be someone you love and it's got
it yeah that's a tough that's depends if
you got a life insurance policy on them
or not that's right
it's not my if it's not your like wife
or kids but a dear friend and it's like
near his ass cheek and it you just see
the [ __ ] snake away and he's like
dude you got to suck it out within I'd
be like I don't know dude let me see if
I get reception or whatever
I'm trying to squeezing it like it's a
pimple like ah dude that's a tough one
dude
[Laughter]
there's no truth that peeing on Jelly
jellyfish stings makes it better really
that was just a freak just trying to pee
on his buddy no I mean I heard this I
swear some french guy soft
some french guy in San Tropez
no no they should do this too and they
said do this he said put your finger in
my ass it works better that's what they
said
if you suck my way how does that even
it's not even related you say we get out
of here get a room what do you think
enough about the jellyfish let's go
let's go to dinner I need to put my
balls in your mouth
says you got to put this lipstick on I
got an 18 Pinot Noir let's just [ __ ] him
you like red or wine what do you like
little woozy from the Venom
oh [ __ ] dude oh [ __ ] okay all right man
these are tough let's go
man these episodes give me headaches
dude dude I'm crying already man like
this is wild man I get dizzy one of my
favorite it's like the greatest show
ever you're one of my favorite guys in
the sense of it's a coin flip whether
you what you're what you're walking up
if you see it at a club or whatever you
might get you might hey what's up Happy
New Year or a lot of times which is my
favorite you get the angry Paul you
[ __ ] believe this guy but either way
it's my favorite you're the best either
way you're in for a good time happy
polar angry I love you like I get the
only thing that makes me upset about are
you garbage is that like I you guys like
there's sometimes I want to be like hey
dude you like you want to open for me I
know and I'm like I know you guys are
doing your own thing but like I love now
he knows this more than anything I
there's nothing I love more than being
in a green room with somebody I love oh
yeah like for me it's like when I you
know they bring a local guy and it's
just a crap shoot you know yeah it's
tough It's like yeah and you want to be
nice but in your mind you're like dude
if this was my boy
have a good time it's a good time it's
all right man it really is okay let's
talk about rock get money baby rocket
let's talk about not getting jammed up
let's talk about somebody having your
back you signed up for all these
subscriptions you don't even know about
you know what I get you the free trial
which is a dirtbag move that I respect
you sign up for the free trial times
around April you get whacked over the
head with 69.95 do yourself a favor get
over there to Rocket money they look
through all your subscriptions you can
cancel really easily formerly known as
true bill oh yeah so do yourself a favor
it's fantastic guys you can give her the
useless subscriptions with rocket money
right now uh go to rocketmoney.com
garbage also rocket money just sounds
cool I want to be in whatever rocket
money's doing baby rocket money
seriously it could take a few it could
save you a few hundred dollars a year
that's rocketmoney.com garbage cancel
your unnecessary subscriptions right now
at
rocketmoney.com garbage I'm gonna say it
one more time get a pen get a pencil
rocketmoney.com garbage do it okay let's
talk about that bespoke post uh I think
you mean a box of awesome hey gang you
like doing cool [ __ ] you like having
cool stuff you like things that are
awesome do yourself a favor Shake a Tail
Feather and get over there to bespoke
post and get your box of awesome they
team up with small businesses it's cool
guys stuff cool guy [ __ ] I've been
saying it for years outdoor stuff
shakers stuff for the bars stuff for the
house pocket knives it's one of those
things they send you stuff that you're
sitting there and you block you about
break out the cool pocket knife or some
some cool like smoker something they
send you a cool guy [ __ ] so when you're
doing something you got company over
your brother comes or your jerk off
brother comes over you go and he's like
oh where'd you get that I don't know
it's a cool Club on the part of it take
him out of the woods and kill a Grizzly
with it yeah uh just take the quiz at
box of awesome.com they'll pick the
right box of awesome for you you pay a
fraction on the price of what these
boxes are worth Plus 90 of everything
comes from a small Optical brand you get
20 off your first monthly box when you
sign up at boxofallsome.com enter code
garbage at the checkout we got it right
here they sent us that cooler that we
use for the goddamn live stream filled
it with beers it still has water in it
because we're their bags that's box of
all still holding strong though box of
awesome.com code garbage for 20 off your
first box box of awesome.com code
garbage now back to the shop back to the
show
um all right this one this is a good one
this is from George uh is it garbage to
use questions from are you garbage on a
first date to see if you're girl is
worth taking out on a second no I like
it that's pretty [ __ ] amazing you
really find out the nitty-gritty about
them I like that yeah and because
because the questions are so good and
specific specific that you could
actually help a relationship sure yeah
yeah you know figure out yeah of course
I there because it does it does tell you
a lot like how you were raised kind of
where your what your thought process is
like I guess if on the first date I was
talking to a girl she's like yeah I pee
in the shower at the gym I'd be like
well you know let's see if she just
volunteered that out of nowhere yeah but
it also matters the question matters too
like of course yeah you can't you gotta
you can't you gotta be careful the one
thing when I look back at my
relationship I would have liked to have
known not that it's that big of a deal
but I would have liked to have known how
she got her steak done because that's
what she do is that a game changer for
you she'd do well share a [ __ ]
porterhouse with her Paul no you'd hate
my wife what does she do she goes she
goes well Well butterfly Well
butterfly well she can't do it she can't
do it she can't do she what yeah my wife
is and unfortunately my son Lucas has
kind of Taken on Stacy that could change
my grandmother but no she'll like cut
chicken and she's looking in it dude and
if there's anything other than white she
just there's something that I don't know
what happened in her head I kind of have
that with chicken I had a chicken yeah
she she's just like and you know but I'm
getting her slowly more to fish I'm
getting her into Seafood I'm getting her
into things but it's tough man so if you
guys go to a steakhouse yeah she's she's
you can't get the porterhouse you can't
share it no you just got to get the
filet or the strip or the rib eye it's
the rib eye is okay she goes well man
it's tough I know man I know dude you
just see the disappointment on the
waiters I look at them I'm like I know I
know sorry what can I do half of the
time though I'm like what the [ __ ] do
you care it's also part of it like what
do you think
I'm like she's a great mother yeah don't
judge her on this alone
my kids are [ __ ] doing great in
school
look at that
yeah yeah it's a tough it's really tough
like she'll just get a filet butterflied
and I just kind of look away I go to the
bathroom
as soon as the waiter comes I'm just
like yeah she looks up you're in another
table
I didn't realize
I thought this was my family
but Sharon and I because listen the
porterhouse has now taken over where the
porterhouse and you can't get it for one
you got to get her for two and if you
can't share that and I'll tell you what
you want to see [ __ ] I just learned
about that you want to see a waiter in
[ __ ] Gallagher's Head Start spinning
around when you say can you do half of
it medium half of a medium round oh yeah
they holy [ __ ] yeah yeah [ __ ] freak
out it's funny that that really is funny
and I don't know how to take that how do
you take when a waiter or somebody that
works there gets
upset dude I remember I think it is
proper disrespect yeah shut the [ __ ] up
I've been on the other end of that after
so long I was in Europe town I was in in
uh Philly years ago years ago young and
I didn't know how to order a cheese
stick it was the one it was on South
Street uh gym gems and I remember dude
this dude comes up and he just goes hey
how do you want yeah can I get a Philly
cheese steak and he just went like this
he went uh like he just and I'm going I
didn't know I don't know and there you
don't know and like but now I'm kind of
like now I'm like it's like dude [ __ ]
you yeah
giving you money dude of course yeah
they did that that the Philly there's
like a handful not most of them some of
them get like real we refused the right
to serve anybody if you don't order the
right way it's like dude shut the [ __ ]
up and give me my [ __ ] state if
you're off from out of town how you
supposed to know like how are you
supposed to know the lingo we didn't go
to a [ __ ] State class yeah I don't
like when you go get sushi they're like
oh it's his choice and I'm like is it
it's his choice because I'm spending
160. just because you just because you
ordered too much eel doesn't mean I
gotta [ __ ] eat it I'm getting [ __ ]
six baby pieces is something that for
160. I don't care what this [ __ ]
thinks I should be you gotta carry a
little clout to be pulling that move you
know what I mean yeah
yeah that's right yeah the chef's got to
be like top yeah he's got to have a
recipe just got promoted from the prep
kitchen up to the you know what I mean
hey it's Randy's choice tonight Randy
what are you talking about
It's gotta be umizumo or something like
that jellyfish you just pissed all over
it you're gonna love it
they're big dick here hit it with the
butane lighter yeah you got you got a
specific urine just that did something
you got to be an established Japanese
sushi chef to get that kind of stuff and
listening for a great place if I went in
knowing that if if they were like hey
you're gonna go to this place it's gonna
cost you 300 bucks that's what they did
a documentary on it yeah that's in like
the train station it sucked yeah oh
really
crazy though oh did so so yeah you go
into this place and it's like the
minimum is 300 bucks and you basically
sit there and it's like on them and you
just you just just tasty menu but you
know that you know this guy's been doing
it for 70 years you know that he's
picking and choosing that's different
than like if me and my family want to go
out and strip mall in [ __ ] New
Rochelle yes
Avatar just cost me 300 bucks give me
what the [ __ ] I want nobody else can get
away with that that's funny
uh all right let's go to a Carrabba's
ah you got the chicken picante shut up
give me my phone he's doing all ravioli
today well let's do it all right
I never liked Benihana man I never liked
it he was uh he got trouble right yeah
he got jammed up yeah
isn't that Steve aoki's dad is that the
guy I'm thinking I believe so yeah yeah
uh I got in trouble with the Wolf of
Wall Street people I was never a fan the
Throne of the food to a fat guy do
hibachi for the kid's birthday yeah for
the kid's birthday they like it the
volcano the flipping of shrimp yeah the
guy throws an egg in his hat you know
it's like
that's the most
small fursy line of all time you do
Hibachi yeah I got those those are
negatives half the [ __ ] you want from me
this guy flips an egg up but goes in his
head he cracks it in a thing you know
kids enjoy it
oh for sure you're gonna be like he
starts doing those tricks like hey buddy
enough with a joke give me the chicken
fried let's do it it's a Burberry
sweater all right I don't want [ __ ]
egg yolk all over this yeah this guy's
gonna throw [ __ ] hot oil on my
cashmere sweater set me on fire I'm
trying to [ __ ] pay for a kid's
birthday party here I got third degree
burns I gotta go to the [ __ ] ER
because this guy's got a volcano near my
cashmere sweater
after he dropped Cashmere
he had to let you know he's flexing on
you a little bit he's saying No this
ain't no [ __ ] you squirt that jerk
off
what do you think this is half cotton
half polyester yeah put that [ __ ]
onion somewhere else
uh
oh [ __ ] dude
this is an all-timer dude
watch when you squirt
[ __ ] it's [ __ ] hot oil going
everywhere and [ __ ] I got somewhere to
be
oh my God
but I think my kids are getting over it
though too like I think it gets
announced yeah it's like after a while
it's you know they they squirt in the
mouth they do all that stuff they throw
the and then all of a sudden the kids
are like all right let's do something
else I don't think I went to college the
most ethnic food we did Growing Up was
Italian that was that was the furthest
right Rogers that was the furthest we
went right we were in Applebee's family
most of the time I remember my buddy's
going we're going to Hibachi I'm like
wait you got your passport
we're 11 dude the [ __ ] you talking about
don't tell my dad
my Pop Pop's gonna be pissed
kids I feel like kids today just I've
noticed my my cousins and my niece and
nephew they have a little bit of a of a
of a deeper palette like you know if
they're exposed to waves way more yeah
yeah yeah which is good your kids eat
sushi
uh yes like like Lucas likes like it's
weird though Lucas I mean this is
another one this is a tough one you
ready for this one yeah Lucas doesn't
eat cheese on his pizza man it's tough
what do you mean so he takes the cheese
off he ordered like a sauce pie and it's
like my older brother Christian who uh
yeah man like he just something with
cheese and dairy my older brother uh my
older brother had something happen with
Derek that was bad when he was young
gotcha so that just [ __ ] freaked him
out but my son that never happened with
my son but my son will get a pepperoni
pizza he takes the pepperoni off and
stacks it on the side takes the cheese
off and then puts the pepperoni on the
thing and eats it like that my daughter
eats anything that's why yeah they put
the pepperoni back on I used to take the
cheese off and just eat the cheese like
a little fat kid oh no I used to love
that my dad used to love watching people
take the cheese off because my dad would
be like oh yeah give me that home oh
yeah yeah yeah nice wad of mozzarella
just starting to get cooled off
you know what your kid would like tomato
pie you'd like tomato pie it's a big
film
is that kind of what they do in Chicago
or no no no no this is it's uh it's like
a sicilian kind of but it's a square pie
and they really reduce the sauce down
when they bake it because there's no
cheese on it so all the water evaporates
and it gets real it's almost like tomato
paste it has a little sweetness to it
does he do a little parmesan he's
talking to us so detailed
anytime you get a [ __ ] rocket
scientists haven't explained things
Toby get my whiteboard will you it
evaporates down to the molecule he was
like so tight it's so good Paul it's so
good it's cold it's cold though you
gotta wait for it to hit 32 degrees and
then you add the parmesan cheese if you
have I got a lab coat on
and a bib are your kids doing sports yet
yeah dude ah sons of Sun's a baller
here's the deal this is the first year
oh my God I can't believe I didn't tell
you this yet this is the first year
um that I decided because I have my
schedule and it's you know I couldn't be
a head coach for my daughters I couldn't
be a head coach for my daughter's fifth
and sixth grade basketball team because
of my schedule but I'm very very close
with the guy who's the head coach
because his daughter's friends with my
daughter and I said look I'll be your
assistant and I've been to every game on
the sidelines and I'm I'm at the
practices yeah you're shaving points
Mr free throw I got money on no there's
a couple of coaches that like take the
[ __ ] real seriously which bothered me
and one of the coaches was like we're
gonna smoke you and like when I heard
that I I got serious at practice yeah
all the girls I call the girls in I said
everybody's expecting us to lose I gave
him a [ __ ] I gave him a speech like
[ __ ] Kurt Russell and miracles these
little girls were staring at me like is
this really that big we're gonna kick
these call me back says I was like they
said there's no chance
did this little girl just looked at her
mom like I don't know
and uh and I was like you got a short
sleeve button down and a sport coat on
but I love it dude and my daughter loves
me there that's good you know and I'm
just like sometimes she gets mad at me
because she takes me still as Dad and
I'm like look I'm just trying to help
you but it's fun man on that court I'm
coach versus
Paul
oh man look at that yeah it's fun it's
fun man being there for like being there
for them it's really fun that's good
have you had any dust-ups with another
parent at all either opposing team or
your team yeah like hey buddy relax a
little bit has that calm down a little
bit no dude it was really bad in like
the mid 2000s
my family gets tossed has been tossed oh
no really there's been fathers there's
been one guy one guy uh I think I heard
uh he coached uh six six-year-old soccer
boys he kicked the ball just far into
another field and he said now you get it
[ __ ] to one of the kids like he's not
allowed on the property anymore like
yeah like some of these guys but dude
there was a mother whose daughter was on
the other team and the door very good
and older than our girls and my my
daughter stole it from her I'm like I
just I got hyped yeah so I'm like yeah
like I I dude I sure I turned into like
it's exciting man dude I turned into
like courtside at the Garden sure I was
like yeah that's you and obviously
everybody hears it putting the mom in
the headlock was a little while
Paul will agree to that so then the
mother heard me because the sidelines
kind of cheered that her daughter got
its stolen but it is my daughter who
stole it sure but then when it came down
the mother was vocalist take it from her
like it was uh it was almost like I
stood trying to match yeah you two were
battling right that's what happened like
without without us really battling we're
battling and you could feel it and then
afterwards everybody like separates and
everybody high fives and you realize
it's just a game you kind of just like
all right yes we'll see you girls next
time
your kids want pizza so it's ice cream
yeah yeah it's it's
you're at a chunky cheese with a broken
clipboard
I'm just leaning over to the mother
while the girls are in the ball pit I'm
like my bad
I got carried away I don't even know
we're on the same team I apologize
listen it was four to two
show me the doctor's bill I apologize
yeah these girls go to the foul line
they shoot like one for 38 I'm [ __ ]
freaking out
for the front of the ramp oh man get mad
about it use the square
I love the verses Knee Deep In The Burbs
out there yeah I love it love and life I
love it holding up in the Lexus that's
good dude I could do this podcast for
[ __ ] three days ah thank you how's
the equipment up there you guys
well-funded Organization for the Hoops
for the for the coaching yeah yeah good
uniforms all that stuff yeah you know
just standard stuff but we have we have
everything we just they just passed a
law a bill or whatever that uh didn't
pass for a long time to get a new turf
field up there okay so we're yeah we got
uh it's good yeah nice you guys know I'm
not gonna live in you know yeah sure I
mean where am I living okay you know of
course I'll set the top of the hill on a
mountain I showed up to the vote for the
third thing he's out there
vote Yes on Turf huh coincidence Paul
got the contract to build it
oh no show jobs too listen a couple
friends helped out but that's you know
it's just it's good Benny's
it's better for the kids knees we're
looking out for the children here
but Paul an eight million dollars hey
you want the best you got to pay for it
and kaparzi constructed I'd like to
thank caparsi Construction
menu
I'll [ __ ] up everything I'll have
kids yeah get that nachos out of here
there'll be Sushi over there get some
crab cakes at least a gentlemen that's a
snack bar all Italian menu yeah this is
just little kids getting cappuccinos and
[ __ ] Expressions they're like wow
furzie really invested in his community
man what kind of red you got why the
[ __ ] are the buses have green leather
I'm a white letter not white buses man
trying to play soccer with a belly full
of eggplant rolling teen holy [ __ ]
hmm
why are all these clam shells all over
the floor why are we at this restaurant
after the season my daddy used to take
us to ice cream and pizza yeah that's
because your dad's a cheap [ __ ] loser
and get whatever you want now pick which
bottle of wine you want
in French
it's prosciutto and melon don't forget
to don't forget your prosciutto
that's all right man that's snack bar
that'd be fun just a Skillets going back
there the Flames we fire we fire all the
fat old chicks that we're serving the
food can we get some young attractive
people here
86 to California down the line get those
apps out and fire the away bleachers
get that [ __ ] old moose with the
[ __ ] fishnet head thing out of here
[Music]
welcome to Dean Martin field everybody
instead of the national anthem it's
Sinatra Fly Me to the Moon
better not be kneeling for this
that's one of you [ __ ] kneeling
oh all right oh [ __ ] that's all right oh
my gosh that's valet parking at all the
games
foreign
[Applause]
oh it's all right it hurts it actually
it actually physically hurts people can
you get me a water please I got I'm like
I'm running hot dude
this would be one of the funniest
moments I've ever done in a podcast ever
dude the mobbed up in the mural game oh
my God I just picture like kids turning
around from a little snack bar where
like a you know a plated chicken parm
and [ __ ] oh that visuals oh the visuals
thank you buddy thank you bud
ah all right Jesus
oh
it's funny I feel like I went to the gym
dude I know peed in the shower
all right what do you say we turn these
cameras on fire
oh you ready well I would be so
disappointed but guys I don't know what
I got left
we'd be on Hiatus for three weeks I'm
guessing oh [ __ ] all right all right you
got more questions
so what you've been up to Paul
how are you doing this summer
okay all right
um new turf field though that's nice
that is good it's all right it's good
um all right let's see here this is from
Brandon
um
is it garbage to double dip but on the
second dip you turn the chip sideways to
the part you didn't bite what do you
think about that if you bite and then
you re you do the back end of it which I
respect I took gentlemen it's a
gentleman move it depends how big the
chip is it can't be close to the fir if
it's a nice big like we're talking a big
Toast restaurant size Tostitos yeah if
you get the rest because they sell the
restaurant style which they could be a
little flimsy though they can break they
can break dudes that's unacceptable it
is you get a bad stop then you're gonna
go fishing around digging around let's
say you got a sturdy big one all right
okay you got one that's not gonna break
if if you bite a piece and there's more
than like three quart more than half
left I actually think it's a respectable
move but but you gotta show the people
yeah you gotta sure like you gotta like
show that you're making a conscious
effort 100 to do it that that I'll give
a pass to you're saying it can't be
small enough that where the finger
imprint no it's going in there and you
can't get any kind of sauce on the
finger and then sure yeah sure I
completely agree with that that is the
gentleman's move because it's like
because then you're gonna run out of
chips everybody's doing one dip one chip
if you get sauce on a finger and then
lick and try to do you should be shot
and killed sure
you can't lick you can't lick anything
there's no licking communal things have
to be napkin what you know what I mean
yes like if you're at a party and
there's a table like this and there's
you gotta you're not in your house right
you're in public 100 try to try to act
like a little bit of a gentleman yes not
a complete Dirtbag that's a good
question that question means that this
person's like thinking thinking about it
yeah of course yes
double dips out double dip on the same
side you're just an animal yeah unless
you're with the a loved one where it's
Yeah by yourself yeah all bets are off I
mean maybe pre-covet you know like I
can't do it with your wife
back at the house with a thing of salsa
I could do it with my I could do with my
wife but it's still like I don't like
the whole I I don't disagree I I have
weird stuff with that as well so I I
understand it but I just like I'm a
separate dip a separate bite for it's
more of a proportion thing like I want
yeah I want it nice I don't want like a
little bit of a crumbled chip I want it
nice every time I'll be honest with you
so I like the Scoops the Scoops are
you're in and out one and done there's
no even attempts the Scoops Don't even
let you get it's not even up for
discussion you're double dipping a scoop
you got [ __ ] yeah one bite Scoops one
bite yeah yeah and I'll admit this since
covet since I know that eyes are on
especially a bigger guy like me eyes are
on me like what's this fat pig gonna do
it's gonna be knuckle deep in this dip I
go real heavy on that first day you
gotta I go real heavy oh just to get
make sure you get yours yes
I go real heavy I go real if I know that
I'm probably not going to be able oh you
know because of the Quorum is go back in
I'm getting my doomsday prepping you you
go for it you just know you gotta get it
gotta get it early dude I'll walk away
after that first one but I'm going heavy
I may have just revolutionized finger
foods at a party just now hearing you
guys what do you got uh-oh you do Scoops
but you fill them up like five like five
layer dip or like an individual nacho
that's a little too much though who's
gonna that's a lot it's a lot of prep
work wait you mean having them ready
yeah that's nuts I mean that's hours of
prep work for an easy dip that they're
gonna be like oh this germaphobe's party
yeah you have to wear the rubber gloves
while you do it too Jesus Christ I took
my shoes off at the door
you got those little booties on your
feet like in [ __ ] like Wahlberg
I got the greatest idea of all time
you're nuts and for that reason I'm out
I got the greatest I'm gonna show
everybody I'm an OCD lunatic
put the chips in one room and dip it
another
have one of those like germ sprays when
you walk in
yeah to nitrogen or whatever
oh man uh all right this one is the same
uh in the same gang uh it's from Logan
haven't had one red is it garbage or
cook hot dogs in the microwave on just
the round glass plate no Tupperware no
paper towel no plate just bare hot dog
on it depends how clean it is yeah and
if you wipe it down it depends if you
have a super clean microwave and then
you do that and as soon as you take it
out you gotta you wipe it down that's
that's you know it's a microwave I I'm
I'll let that slide but I think if
you're trying not to use a plate you're
probably not wiping down the microwave
and your microwave isn't clean but
shouldn't you put the hot dog around a
paper a paper should be around the hot
dog or no I think that is the proper way
to do it in the microwave I think yeah
because it doesn't burn like it won't
crack the hot dog towel and then put it
on all right I think so yeah I like when
it cracks open I do I do as well I think
it looks better that way T-Bone you
looking
yeah yeah I think that is the proper way
it's Gotta like the same thing it's like
putting a little if you redo the they
have like those microwavable Lids sure
sure dude a hot dog and a microwave just
says there's nothing else in the house I
love them it's one of my favorites
really dude two Oscar Meyer cheese
though yeah but you're not doing that
with a chicken cutlet in the [ __ ]
I cannot yeah if you've got a car right
I love it I love it so two fresh potato
rolls that's good oh cheese dogs yeah
you're not pushing aside chicken farm to
grab a hot dog to throw in the microwave
let's get rid of that clams casino right
any diesels back there
the desperation of a microwave hot dog
yeah yeah it's all right uh paper towel
in the microwave is to trap moisture so
that it steams a little bit and prevents
bladder yeah yeah I think that is the
proper you know the proper way a
gentleman would that's how that's how
one of the Kennedys would microwave
their if you want to know if somebody's
a [ __ ] animal look in their microwave
because if it's like splattered sauce
like somebody got their brain yeah
you're just like this person and you
know it's been there a while yeah it's
been there a while it's gross or the
juice on the glass plate that's that's
disgusting like when it's just caked
over and you clearly hasn't been washed
that's a tough one yeah that's a tough
one you can learn a lot about it would
you ever use the microwave at like a
7-Eleven or a convenience store
it it would have to be a desperate uh
apocalypse
[Laughter]
yeah remember I told you I had a
thousand bullets there'd be like eight
left
[Laughter]
tank here I'm on my last magazine let's
go get some nachos
yeah cause that last bullet for myself
the grid would have to be down
but you do you do make gross decisions
higher drunk sure like if you're if
you're I think I'm sober if you're six
beers in and high and you're going to a
7-Eleven I think all bets are wrong I've
said this a bunch I've done it this year
to Pizza the 7-Eleven after you got a
couple in you I don't shake a stick at
it's all right yeah yeah it's all right
yeah drunk you got a couple in you if as
long as it's a little crispy and hot
does it you know especially on the road
man we like if you're like you gotta eat
at a gas station or something if you're
driving somewhere it's like you gotta
[ __ ] remember me and you went to that
cigar place so they had those uh fajitas
in Houston yeah we were like starving
and they were like oh that's good it was
a little cold but you know they did oh
that's right there was like a party or
something like that it's like a party
like before we got there and they were
like hey you invited us in and I was
like are you gonna and it was like like
peppers and onions sternos were out but
they're still a little ones you know
what I had about 15 fajitas
15 fajitas some Scotch well the cigars
the cigar wouldn't have been as good if
we didn't eat no yeah we had Dukes
probably yeah we had to
funny
um that's I got I asked verzie about
when I got him reservations at the
Macanudo Club yes Club mcanoodle oh we
haven't gone yet but okay yeah yeah just
make sure you win make sure yeah just
got to wear it dress up just wear a
collared shirt and and you can't have
sneakers cool what's it like but but
they they see joint but like I want the
food
great
not too smoky yeah I was in there
massive like you'll see some people you
know who used to Carmelo Anthony is
always in there
um
Eli Manning and his father remembers
there there you go uh yeah I was sitting
there one time I think it was like
offensive lineman and I thought you said
it had his fat father members there
that's what I thought you said oh no I
mean in his fat father I was like what
the [ __ ] Archie Manning put on weight
what do you got against the big guy no
it's it's good man you'll see like there
was a lot of like big linemen from like
football teams in there and sometimes I
play like they'll be just somebody in
there playing the harp [ __ ] nice I got
TVs up you know you know you made it
there's a harp around yeah dude I went
in there with sneakers one time and they
were like you can't and they were like
but we got a you know uh you know a draw
full of slippers and they [ __ ]
checked my sneakers walking around there
and [ __ ] slippers yeah and they even
you could even throw like jackets on if
you can't so what I did was I I'm not
I'm wearing a t-shirt then I'll let them
dress me they don't have quadruple X ah
[ __ ] I mean maybe for the line man I
don't know but I had what I would do is
I would drive with dress shoes and a
collared shirt in my trunk always in
case I went there so I'd be outside Club
Mac I would be outside of club Mac just
changing after sex
I thought you were a homeless person
that's all right that's class right
there this guy's not ready for zombies
but he's ready for a nice Chardonnay you
ain't get it dude that no to go back but
I got cologne in the in in the trunk
I'll tell the zombie give me a second
before you eat me let me just finish
this [ __ ] dab it off
at this [ __ ] account where the zombie
gets him he acts like when the feds come
they put he puts a suit on to get like
for the purple
if you're gonna I try to give the zombie
a hit dude dude just here listen this is
a McAllen 18.
oh all right let's do a couple of more
here uh this is from Matthew ever taking
a celebrity picture to the barber to
show them how you want your hair to look
I ain't never done that I have never
even like picked it off the wall or like
give me I've picked it off the wall and
they slipped like in the 90s they slip a
couple celebrities in those things when
you look at like the big one like in the
corner you'll be like is that yeah he's
talking about on his phone though right
he's not gonna show up with a picture
yeah that's how I pictured him I hit a
hard copy what an egg bite with like a
headshot an eight by ten William Morris
to get [ __ ] get a haircut
John travolt eating a piece of pizza
yeah yeah you got Nick Cage's head shot
from what he did in a rock
I never thought of that uh no we never
did that they did have the books but I
always felt like they couldn't really
also I was a fat kid you know like you
didn't have that I didn't have that head
were you a fat kid yeah yeah yeah really
yeah yeah yeah oh wow like all through
high school and [ __ ] yeah there was like
periods where I was like trimmed down
but like yeah for I was fat my whole
life really yeah yeah
[Laughter]
yeah like he's been like like he was up
for the Heisman
oh no [ __ ] he really bounced back and
became a fat comedian
I thought you were like a thousand dips
a day I did say that it was such shock
like I was an astronaut you really were
able to overcome that become fatter in
your Bruce Jenner transition
like like boys haircut like haircuts for
kids and and you'll get a bunch so then
you could just go and show the barber
but to bring a picture of a celebrity
the way he questioned it yeah made the
question that's a little much yeah
that's all like I want to look like Brad
Pitt in whatever that's so that's a
little wonky to me right and I think
with iPhones you don't need to have it
you could just you don't got a hard copy
on you yeah yeah does your your son have
the does he have a cool haircut all my
nieces and nephews all have the cool my
son's got that you know dirty blonde
like you know he's got the blue you know
he could look like a surfer kid he's got
you know so he could just go in however
is he big into the sneakers huge yeah
huge bigger than me yeah yeah bigger
than me they're real the kids are real
big he's he's you know he knows all he
knows things I don't know yeah you know
and then there'll be things that I'm
like look at those those are great he's
like Dad those stink but not not the
Vintage the Vintage door and he's like
yeah those are nuts but if I see a pair
he's just like they have their own their
own view it's like their view of
sneakers today is so different it's
weird crazy yeah yeah of course my
nephew got upset because of the way I
was he was trying to try him on in a
store and the way I unlaced them he got
upset he's like you're ruining them yeah
I was like I'm ruining them he's like
hey you ripped burrito why are you
chewing on that
he like grabbed them out of my hand and
put them on they don't like to get him
he was walking around the other day like
Frankenstein because he didn't want to
crease I don't want to crease him up
yeah oh no I I that's that's the big
joke that all my friends have on me like
I'll walk on my heels I remember one
time we were in some City and they were
I just heard my friends Kaka laughing
because I was walking on my heels
waddling in like cold weather in
Minnesota because I had new Jordans on
and I actually ended up pulling a muscle
in my leg because I was walking along
my hip was all [ __ ] up and I was like
it was off balance
you're like what were you doing old
football injury nah I got a pair of this
new pair of Jordans guys
just put the new hip in well yeah I
gotta get out of here
uh you know what do you know the dude uh
sneaker suplex in Philly that dude ever
hit you up no it's a good dude Mikey hit
him out there they got [ __ ] great
[ __ ] yeah I had a bunch of I had a bunch
of people like hit me he's a good
sneaker dude oh is he oh that I love
having hookah that's the hookup you want
he's awesome yeah he's good to shout out
to him I'll take that over like a deli
hookup oh yeah I'll buy a sandwich you
know yeah yeah get me some [ __ ] no one
else has that's yeah that's funny when
someone's like dude you come in I make
you the best sandwich really yeah it's
gonna drive 30 miles to get a [ __ ]
get an Italian hoagie [ __ ] we doing I'll
do the sandwich
it's like it's not getting crazy Foley's
like when you say like crazy sandwich
what are we talking here
how crazy we talking some new kind of
mayo I don't know he's talking about it
like it's phone sex so what are you
putting on that thing
you know the bread is soft roast the
peppers come on all right let's do one
more then we gotta wrapper up here uh
this one's from Brian never have one red
is it garbage that my neighbor's growing
up and my dad got into so many heated
arguments they built a bigger fence
between us
have you ever had any of that in the
burbs yes any territory beats that's big
on like Tick Tock and Instagram yeah
those videos what happened was when I
moved into my house somebody goes hey
just so you know your neighbor and the
guy before you battled it was like which
body are they gonna find first really
and like they were like it was a big
thing so then you have space too you
know you're on top of it and I heard
like to the point where like leaves they
throw like I heard it got to like a big
thing and then it's such a disrespect
you throw leaves on my property I don't
care but I'm like it's the disrespect it
gets me I'm like we're gonna fight like
if you see the leaves you don't care but
if you see a dude take it tray and
[ __ ] throw it over that's a different
that's a different thing
um so what the guy that lived in my
house did was he just put up giant trees
and and you know it made life easier so
I think I don't think it's garbage I
actually think you're preventing a
problem a bigger a bigger fence it's
like you know what you kind of there's a
barricade there now and it's like you
don't like me I don't like you so let's
let's [ __ ] it yeah I think that that's
it's more garbage to fight and always be
fighting and having you know throwing
[ __ ] yelling [ __ ] oh what are you gonna
do that's why I would end up with those
people a couple years ago remember that
bad snowstorm it was in Pennsylvania
these two neighbors were beefing with
each other guy goes in the house gets
his piece across the street comes out
and kills the two people shoots the
husband and a wife oh wasn't that like
on camera or something yeah yeah over
[ __ ] shoveled snow or something I
mean I don't think offense is stopping
that guy
she's pretty dead settled you guys gonna
come out with a 12 gig you go ah [ __ ]
there's a defense you know what's up God
damn it there goes that plan no of
course he just pulls his head off
because there's a fence sure well like
what you're saying just you know nip it
in the bud so it doesn't get to that
point yeah because when you hear like
I've heard stories of like oh they fight
they screams one gets drunk one comes
out like fighting on your lawn and it's
like yeah that's trash no that's yeah I
remember my brother is his old house
didn't there was like the the driveways
were on a hill like yeah him and his
neighbors they were like going up a hill
and the people there before him had
looped had connected to the two
driveways so the guy's wife could not
have to back down oh my brother's right
driveway okay but then my brother would
just like pull up and kind of block the
the loop because it was his driveway and
the guy's like he can't you can't park
there I was like it's my [ __ ]
driveway wow like you can you can use it
when I'm not there but like wow and he
came out and yelled at my sister-in-law
he's like you can't park there my
brother's like I will block my brother's
like how would I just get a [ __ ] how
about I get a jackhammer and just
Jackhammer that [ __ ] out and then we
don't have to ever [ __ ] think about
it again dude nothing worse my my
stepfather had a neighbor and he would
just park multiple cars in the front
lawn and my stepfather said he would
dream about it he would [ __ ] hell it
was like we'd be playing golf and he
would just I'd see him go like [ __ ]
Tony yeah yeah like and I was like what
do you like are you worried about your
shot you know and he would be like nah
this [ __ ] guy's got six cars in the
thing and I can't and then finally he
went over to the house and he was just
[ __ ] told it and it fixed it but you
can't live like that dude yeah yeah you
can't live with it that's too much yeah
too much especially when it's every day
you think about that imagine pulling
into your house that's where you're
[ __ ] safe dude that's yourself your
whole life you're against everything
right you gotta whether you're tired
whether you feel this you got to travel
then you go home and all of a sudden you
got this [ __ ] and you got to [ __ ] six
cars so I'm [ __ ] Oldsmobile in the
front yard
what'd you say running I said none of
them
no dude you can't have that and I think
that this question is great because it's
just like you know what I'm going to
invest in my piece sure hey of course
I'm gonna invest in a [ __ ] big
offense out of sight out of mind if I
can't see it it's not a problem but I'm
not it's not ruining my day it's not
ruining my golf outing no ruining slap
up a big fence big fence people or you
could have big I know this is it's a
little more expensive but this is the
way I would go just have Joe
I got two words for you mountain lion
all right
in trees like giant trees like ins like
put in yeah you know I mean I'm the
[ __ ] problem just line it up with
like those giant pine trees if you put
the saplings in you're fine you're
playing long game right like the little
ones didn't wait 30 years for that girl
that takes it real seriously it's like
19 German Shepherds
Jesus Christ
it was one birthday party sorry we were
loud man it was it was my 21st well my
neighbor actually threatened threatened
me with a gun after my first fireworks
that's why I told you that Jesus the
woman no no no she's kooky right no I
told you I saw her you so now she's done
write down license plates no see he what
happens I'm not getting involved no
she's there there's a woman he's talking
about that's like out of her mind she
like she heard like like coyotes howling
screaming like she showed up with like
rubber boots and an ax asking if like
there was an animal attacking kids I
mean it was [ __ ] like yeah like
there's one she's just like she needs to
watch a Jurassic Park lady yeah she
needs to be put away but no so the first
year so I'll give you the quick thing I
know you gotta run so my fourth of July
party I do I do big fireworks yeah
not really not really the most legal
right I would say not at all the first
year we did it okay I didn't know I was
like I'm gonna have some people we're
gonna have fireworks I didn't know what
real fireworks were so I do get the ones
in Connecticut in the supermarket that
looked big but like they come up to here
and [ __ ] and my daughter was three years
old and right when it was done you just
heard her oh yeah because this was this
so disappointing yeah so for one [ __ ]
year I told everybody watch now because
you know man you watched me when they
when Paul brought the National Guard in
yeah so so I was like come next year my
little girl so the next year dude we
went like dude I had a friend come up
from the Bronx he goes come out here and
I went to the drive I went to the here's
a tank I went to the driving dude he
opened his trunk and he took this and he
had like not those plastic bags that
like are garbage like you put a body in
this [ __ ] and he opened it up and
there were like rockets dude like I mean
like rockets that like seem like they
should be going to Afghanistan
but the thing that goes up we didn't
know where to line them up so dude we
just had it it turned into I mean dude
bartnick you just oh my people were like
dude I've been to baseball games
like mine dude it was so nuts that but
we were close to the neighbor I didn't
know how high these things were gonna go
so the next day dude it looked like a
[ __ ] Jet Blue refusalage blew up over
this guy's house like this guy's like my
wife's been cleaning up for a half hour
the debris was ever I didn't know though
I mean one of them like like flew into
his yard dude so he's like he's like you
know next year can I talk to you for a
second you know next year I'm gonna be
armed like he was like and I'm like dude
I didn't I didn't know yeah I didn't
know what this kid's gonna bring I
didn't know this kid's gonna bring
something that could blow up a small
country I didn't know I just wanted to
please my daughter because we had
[ __ ] jumping jacks the year before
like the Ukrainian
I'm gonna be hard after it's like you
did it on purpose relax and I go what do
you mean and he was like I'm just saying
I'm gonna be I'm gonna and like it was a
weird thing to say and I kind of it was
just a weird thing to say but um ever
since then but then you know what this
[ __ ] did years later we didn't have a
problem he invited his family and they
all sat on the deck to watch yeah that's
Community baby you know but we still
don't talk but well I'm sure he's coming
to the party next year bring a thing of
[ __ ] Tostitos scoops and we'll have a
nice time yeah
his defense I was lining up Rockets five
feet from his property line
what's this version
but uh yeah I'm all about the fence
[Music]
apparently sending flares over the house
all right we gotta wrap her up ladies
and gentlemen Mr Paul Versi out on tour
right now Netflix special you gotta
check out Paul what do you want the
folks out there maybe guys uh I got a
big tour coming up called the level up
tour I start January 28th at the Royal
Theater in Toronto tickets are going man
I cannot wait to be there then I'm
coming home I'm headlining for the first
time in New York City Gotham Comedy Club
February 2nd and 3rd I'm gonna be uh
Valentine's Day I'm gonna be in
Pittsburgh one night it's a Tuesday
bring your date Pittsburgh improv uh
bringing in the club Pittsburgh's on Joe
bartnick is gonna be uh Joe bartnick's
gonna be opening for me but I'm gonna be
out there and we just guys we added uh
so much I got Tampa coming up I got Salt
Lake City I got Denver I got Texas uh in
Austin I got Chicago coming up I got
Rhode Island just last night we got
Charlotte we got Raleigh go to
paulversey.com all the tickets are
available I'm doing a brand new hour uh
and and I think it's the best hour that
I've ever done even better than
nocturnal emissions which is crushing on
Netflix right now
um so yeah man so I hope to see you guys
man go to the shows but uh yeah so the
first three are uh Toronto New York City
Pittsburgh love you guys man we love you
buddy gang if you haven't seen Paul do
yourself a [ __ ] favor and check them
out oh and real quick my new my so my
version effect podcast is now in a
studio like this it's doing fantastic on
YouTube the Versi effect I also co-host
anything better with Bill Burr and uh we
do uh bet MGM picks for football so the
whole thing go to my YouTube channel
Paul verzie there you go vir-z-i thank
you buddy
uh we're all we're going to be
announcing our dates coming up stay
tuned for that get tickets to the live
shows they're moving quick we love yous
thank you see you next week peace